ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an
ask-me-anything or AMA
episode, which is part of our
premium subscriber content.
Our premium channel
was launched in order
to raise support for the
standard Huberman Lab podcast
channel, which still comes
out once a week every Monday.
And of course, is
zero cost to consumer.
The premium channel
is also designed
to support exciting
research being
done at major universities
like Stanford and elsewhere,
research that's done on humans
that should lead to protocols
for mental health,
physical health,
and performance in
the near future.
If you'd like to check out the
premium channel subscription
model, you can go to
hubermanlab.com/premium
and there you can subscribe
for $10 a month or $100 a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscriber option.
For those of you that are
already Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers and you're
watching and/or hearing this,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the
premium podcast feed.
And for those of you
that are not already
Huberman Lab premium
podcast subscribers,
you will be able to hear
the first 15 minutes or so
of this episode.
And hopefully, that will allow
you to discern whether or not
you would like to become
a premium subscriber.
Without further ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
And as always, I will strive
to be as accurate as possible,
as thorough as possible, and
yet as concise as possible.
The first question today
is about adaptogens.
Some of you may have
heard of adaptogens.
I'm guessing many of you
have not heard of adaptogens.
The strict definition of
adaptogens is still evolving.
Meaning, no one really
knows what adaptogens mean
and what's included
in adaptogens
and what's excluded
from adaptogens.
But the most common
definition of an adaptogen
is a compound that is typically
a supplement or a drug.
Although, it could be a
behavior, if you really
think about it, that helps you
adapt to and buffer stress.
So when you hear
about adaptogens,
there are three main
categories of adaptogens
that come to mind.
The first are things that
are contained in food.
So these would be
vitamins or micronutrients
that one could
easily find in food.
But one would have to consume
a fairly restricted number
or type of foods in order
to obtain those things,
or consume a lot of
those foods in order
to get sufficient dosages
of those adaptogen compounds
in order to buffer stress.
Some good examples
of these would
be any kind of vitamin, either
water-soluble or fat-soluble,
that can adjust or reduce what
are so-called reactive oxygen
species.
And then that's what
gives rise to this idea
that antioxidants
are good for us.
Now, over the last 10 years
or so, there's been a shift.
What shift has occurred?
Well, about 10 years
ago, you often heard
about antioxidants,
antioxidants, antioxidants
and vitamins,
antioxidants in this food,
this superfood, et cetera.
And why were people
talking about antioxidants?
Well, just to remind you,
reactive oxygen species
are types of reactions
and molecules
that occur in cells when
cells get stressed and/or age.
And antioxidants
are the compounds
that reduce those
reactive oxygen species.
Reactive oxygen species
are bad for cells
because they tend to hinder
the function of mitochondria,
which are associated with energy
production in those cells.
So what do we know for sure?
We know that as cells
get older, or as any cell
or biological
system organ tissue,
et cetera, get stressed
a lot over time,
the number of reactive
oxygen species
increases in those cells
and tissues and organs.
And antioxidants, which can
include certain vitamins
but also some
micronutrients, are
effective in reducing those
reactive oxygen species.
Now, what's occurred
over the last 10 years
is that we know that
reactive oxygen species are
a major source of depleting
cellular function by way
of depleting
mitochondrial function.
But they are just one
of many mechanisms
that can deplete
cellular function
mitochondrial function.
So nowadays, you'll hear
about reactive oxygen species
and antioxidants, but not
as much as you used to.
Now, you hear a lot more
about inflammatory responses
and inflammatory cytokines
also being an issue.
And the truth is all of
these things are an issue.
So going back to this
question about adaptogens,
adaptogens include
these three categories.
I've told you the first,
which are the vitamins
and micronutrients that
are contained in food that
can reduce reactive
oxygen species
and other aspects
of cell or stress,
such as inflammatory cytokines.
What are some of those
things that occur in foods?
Well, in order to
answer that, let's
just think about what
sorts of foods, themselves,
can act as adaptogens.
It's commonly held that the
dark, leafy greens type foods,
for those of you
that eat plants.
And I think the majority of
people out there do eat plants.
I know that the
carnivore diet and lion
diet and some other diets
tend to exclude plants,
and we'll address that
briefly at some point
in today's discussion.
But dark, leafy greens
are known to contain
a number of compounds
in the form of vitamins
and micronutrients that are
very effective in reducing
reactive oxygen species
and inflammatory cytokines.
So if you're somebody
who's interested
in adaptogens and adaptogenic
processes, reducing
stress and buffering stress,
which, of course, has
its role in buffering
daily stress in order
to help you sleep
better to improve
cellular function for
longevity sports performance,
cognitive performance,
that is all good
and it makes sense
why people would
be interested in adaptogens.
But remember that the
two main adaptogens
that you should think
to first are going
to be behaviors and nutrition.
I started with
nutrition on purpose.
As I mentioned, we'll get
to behaviors in a moment.
So if you're interested
in adaptogens at all,
I highly recommend that
you include at least two
to four servings of
dark, leafy greens
and/or cruciferous
vegetables per day.
I think that would be
highly advantageous.
And just be aware that
excessively heating dark,
leafy greens or
cruciferous vegetables
can actually destroy
the very nutrients
and micronutrients that
act in an adaptogenic way.
That does not mean that you
need to eat raw broccoli
or cauliflower, just the thought
of that makes me nauseous,
it's very hard to digest.
Some people might like that
or can digest it more easily
than others.
So it's perfectly fine
to cook your cruciferous
vegetables and
dark leafy greens,
but you don't want
to overcook them.
What's overcooking and
what's undercooking?
There's no strict cutoff
in terms of temperature.
But basically,
what the literature
says is that if you heat
vegetables to the point
where the colored
fluid is leaching out
of them into a broth
type, into water
or whatever fluid surrounds
them, well, then you
would be well off to ingest
that fluid as well because it
contained in the water or
the fluid that's leaching out
from the cruciferous vegetables
or from the dark leafy greens,
are going to be a lot of those
very adaptogenic molecules
that you're interested
in the first place.
OK.
So I probably
surprised some people
by starting off my answer
to the question of "What
are adaptogens?
Are they worth thinking
about in pursuing?
And if so, how can I get
them?" by talking about food.
But I think it is important
to understand that you can get
a lot of adaptogens from food.
And indeed, some of
the best adaptogens
do come from dark leafy greens
and cruciferous vegetables.
So I'd be remiss if I
didn't mention that.
The other two
categories of adaptogens
are going to be supplement-based
adaptogens and then
behavioral adaptogens.
Again, here adaptogen
defined as anything
that can buffer stress in a
substantial or meaningful way
in order to support
cellular health, organ
health, and overall daily
living and functioning,
including sleep and
performance in mental health.
So the second
category of adaptogens
are going to be supplements.
And here, again, I just
want to take a step back,
make sure that we
are clear about
our operational definition
about what a supplement is.
We had an episode all about
how to design a rational guide
to supplementation,
which included,
for example, the idea
that for some people,
the optimal dosage
of many supplements
is going to be zero.
And for other people, the
dosage will be something else.
But to really pinpoint the
key message from that episode
that I'd like to reiterate
now, but a key message
from that episode that
I'd like to reiterate now
is that many people
think of supplements
as just vitamin supplements.
And for that
reason, you'll often
hear the argument, "Oh,
well, aren't supplements just
expensive urine.
Couldn't you get all
of that from food?"
Aren't you just urinating out
all the water-soluble vitamins
and maybe even
storing excess amounts
of the fat-soluble vitamins
in a way that's unhealthy
or not cost-effective?"
And so on.
When we talk about
supplements, yes, it
can include vitamin supplements.
However, there
are many compounds
that we would describe as
supplements that are not
vitamin supplements, and that
you could not obtain from food
or that you could
never obtain from food
in sufficient enough
qualities to have
a robust positive biological
effect without consuming
an enormous number of calories
or overriding your gut
mechanically.
For instance, if there
were, say, a herb, and we'll
talk about such
herbs in a moment,
that contained an
effective adaptogen,
but you would never
want to eat the plant
itself or include that
herb in any kind of recipe,
well then, chances
are this herb, which
we'll define in a moment,
is not a vitamin supplement.
It is probably not even best
thought of as a supplement,
it's best thought
of as a compound
that sold over the counter,
much like a prescription drug.
Although, it's not prescription.
It doesn't require a
prescription to get it.
So there are a lot of
things like that we
include under the umbrella
of this word supplements.
And unfortunately, because
of that, a lot of people
think, "Oh, you don't
need supplements."
And, of course, you don't
need supplements per se,
but many people do derive
tremendous benefit from them.
In the context of
adaptogens, there
are two or three
in particular that
can be very beneficial
for buffering the stress
response, especially,
over short periods of time
of about two to three weeks.
So when would you use these?
Well, for instance, if you are
in a particularly stressful
mode of life, either because of
family or relational or school
or work demands or
new kid in the house
or-- any number of different
things, or you've been ill
or you're recovering
from injury,
taking an adaptogen in
the form of a supplement
can actually be very useful
for buffering this hormone
and the general system
is associated with,
called cortisol.
It's very healthy
to have high levels
of cortisol early in the day,
shortly after you wake up.
And then that ought to taper
off toward the afternoon
and evening.
However, if cortisol
is chronically
elevated throughout the day,
or if that peak in cortisol
is arriving too late
in the day, that
is known to be associated
with mental health
and physical health issues.
Has been shown by labs at
Stanford and elsewhere.
It's been shown in animal
models and in humans.
Talked many times before, and
I'll just remind you again.
One of the best ways to
restrict that cortisol peak
to the early part of the day
is to get morning sunlight
in your eyes as soon as you can.
Once the sun is up,
get outside face
in the direction of the
sun, even on overcast days.
Don't wear sunglasses, look
at it for five to 30 minutes.
Definitely blink so you
don't damage your eyes,
so on and so forth.
Why five minutes or 30 minutes?
Well, five minutes on a clear
day should be sufficient,
longer would be fine.
Again, blink so that
you protect your eyes.
Blink as needed.
Face in the general
direction of the sun.
On days when you have a lot of
overcast or it's really dark,
dense cloud cover,
well, then, you'd
want to be outside longer.
And if you don't have access to
sunlight for whatever reason,
then you want to
do the same thing
with bright artificial lights
indoors, either so-called SAD
lamp or otherwise.
That's a great way to
restrict that cortisol peak
to early in the day.
But even if you're
doing that, if you
have a stressful life
for whatever reason,
even if you're getting that
morning sunlight, which I hope
you are, you're
getting your exercise,
you're trying to sleep
better and more as we all
should most of the
time, well, then you
may be somebody who
wants to take a adaptogen
in the form of a supplement.
And the three
supplements that can
be very effective in
buffering cortisol
are ashwagandha, which I'll
talk about first, lion's mane
and chaga.
Lion's mane and chaga
are in the fungi group,
so they count as mushrooms.
They are not
psychedelic mushrooms.
Let's talk about
ashwagandha first.
Ashwagandha is at
the top of the list
because it is indeed a
very potent adaptogen.
How can I say that?
Well, there are a
number of studies
now, including
several excellent ones
in humans, that
report that taking
two doses of 300 milligrams
of ashwagandha per day
can, very dramatically,
buffer cortisol.
So this is something
that you would
have a near-impossible
time accessing from food.
I can't imagine
that, unless you're
cooking with the very
sources of ashwagandha
and extracting exact
amounts that you'd
be able to get this in any other
form except supplement form.
So here I'm going to just
briefly reference a paper
and we can provide a reference
link to this, that is.
This is a paper
from 2012 that's had
a lot of excellent follow-up
papers that support it.
The title of the paper is
A prospective randomized
double-blind placebo-controlled
study of safety and efficacy
of high concentration
of full spectrum
extract of ashwagandha
root in reducing
stress and anxiety in adults.
And it's a really nice study.
Not a huge subject pool,
but both men and women, and
has carried out for
long enough that they
got to see some really
interesting results.
And I think the most
interesting result
is that taking 300 milligrams
of ashwagandha twice a day
led to enormous--
I mean, just enormous
changes in serum cortisol.
The statistical significance
that they observed in the study
was really fantastic,
fantastically high
statistical significance.
They saw the effects of
ashwagandha on day 15,
having initiated the ashwagandha
consumption on day one,
of course, day 30 and day 45.
And again, this was
dramatic reductions
in stress as
perceived by people.
So subjective stress
and cortisol levels.
So ashwagandha is very
potent at reducing cortisol.
How would you
recapitulate this if you
wanted to use ashwagandha
to buffer stress?
Well, a couple of key points.
I mentioned earlier that
you want your cortisol peak
to come earlier in the day.
Therefore, you would
not want to buffer
cortisol early in the day.
In fact, cortisol
peaking early in the day
provides an anti-inflammatory
immune-supporting, focus
and mood supporting
effect all day long.
So I would recommend
that people take
their first dose of ashwagandha
anywhere from 250 to 300
milligrams.
Sometime in the early afternoon
and again in the evening,
as opposed to taking a morning
dose in an afternoon dose.
Also, if you're somebody
who's exercising
for sake of trying to induce
adaptations like hypertrophy,
the growth of
muscles or strength,
or improve your
endurance in any way,
muscular endurance or more
traditional cardiovascular
endurance, then I recommend that
you not take your ashwagandha
prior to exercise because part
of the adaptation response
is triggered by increases
in cortisol during exercise.
Sort of in the same way
that some of the best
adaptations to exercise are
reductions in blood pressure
and resting heart rate.
And those are stimulated by
increases in blood pressure
and increases in heart
rate during exercise.
That's just how these
biological systems work.
So the takeaway
is pretty simple.
If you're interested in using
ashwagandha as an adaptogen,
I would restrict it
to later in the day
if you can and not
before exercise.
Divide it into two doses
of 250 to 300 milligrams.
That's what this
paper and other papers
like it seem to indicate.
And then a very important
final point about ashwagandha,
which is that if you're
going to take ashwagandha,
I recommend not taking it for
longer than a month-and-a-half
as they did in this study.
In fact, I would
suggest that you only
take ashwagandha around periods
of moderate to extreme stress.
What's moderate,
what's extreme is
going to depend on what
you're going through.
Only how much stress and
life events you can tolerate.
So if you've had trouble
sleeping and that's
unusual for you.
Or, you're dealing with a very
difficult life circumstances
or excessive work demand, or a
new kid, as I mentioned before.
Well, then buffering
stress with ashwagandha,
buffering cortisol in
the afternoon and evening
can be very beneficial for you.
But then I would say after
about 30 days maximum,
I would take at least
two to four weeks off.
Two weeks is probably
enough, but four weeks off
because you don't want to
chronically buffer cortisol.
It's just not a good idea.
But that said, I
think ashwagandha
is a very powerful
adaptogen. I would
place at the top of the list
of supplement-based adaptogens.
But keep in mind
that even if you're
taking a supplement-based
adaptogen,
that's no reason to abandon the
nutrition and behavioral type
adaptogenic effects that you
can create through eating
dark leafy greens,
cruciferous vegetables,
then we'll talk about the
behaviors in a moment.
The other two supplement-based
adaptogens, as I mentioned,
are lion's mane
mushroom and chaga.
And I get asked a lot about
lion's mane and chaga for sake
of their purported roles in
acting as nootropics as quote
unquote "smart drugs."
There are fewer data
on the beneficial roles
of lion's mane and chaga for
sake of nootropic effects--
we'll do an entire episode
on nootropics at some point.
But there have been
a few studies showing
that lion's made in
supplementation and chaga
supplementation
can improve memory,
and maybe even
divergent thinking
associated with creativity
and things of that sort.
Again, these are not
psychedelic mushrooms.
That said, there are good data
showing that 1,000 milligrams,
that is 1 gram, of lion's
mane per day and/or--
I will talk about the
end/or portion in a moment,
and/or chaga mushroom at 500
to 1,500 milligrams per day
can act as adaptogens in,
again, reducing cortisol.
But also and mainly reducing
some of the anti-inflammatory
cytokines that are known to
circulate in high abundance
when you're under a lot of
psychological and/or physical
stress.
Things like interleukin 6
and some related molecules.
So here's what I
would recommend.
If you are interested
in exploring adaptogens,
I'm a big fan, as
some of you probably
know, if you heard that
episode on rational guide
to supplementation.
I'm a big fan of mainly
focusing on taking supplements
in single-ingredient
formulations
so that you can figure out
what dosages are best for you,
and so that you can toggle in
and out those adaptogens as
needed.
So I, of course,
am a fan of taking
certain blends and mixes,
the one that we talk
about a lot on this
podcast and we have been
a sponsor from the beginning,
I've taken for a decade
now long before I
ever had a podcast,
is Athletic Greens, which
some of you might note
does contain some ashwagandha.
Although, the levels
of ashwagandha
that are contained
in Athletic Greens
are low enough that I don't see
any issue with taking Athletic
Greens consistently, day to
day, every day, because you're
not getting anywhere near
that 600-milligram dosage.
But the idea is that
if you were going
to take any adaptogen for
sake of buffering stress
over the short term, say for a
week or two weeks or a month,
and then taking that
recommended time off,
I would start with ashwagandha.
And then if you feel you
need something else to buffer
stress, keeping in
mind, of course,
that you're doing the behavioral
and the nutritional things
to buffer stress as well.
You can never
abandon those, right?
Well, then I would suggest
adding 1,000 milligrams
or 1,000 milligrams
of chaga per day
and seeing how that further
benefits your system in terms
of buffering stress.
How would you measure if
your stress is being reduced?
Well, you're going to be
sleeping better at night.
You're going to feel
subjectively better, lower
levels of anxiety.
All the things that are
measured in the types of studies
I described before.
Now, of course, there's
nothing preventing you
from taking 600
milligrams of ashwagandha,
a gram of lion's mane,
and a gram of chaga.
I know some people
like to just kind of go
full tilt into everything.
But I am a big believer in
really trying to isolate which
supplements and molecules work
best for you and which ones
don't.
Do you need to cycle on and
off lion's mane and chaga?
I'm not aware of any
data showing that you do.
If, however, you're
taking them every day,
I recommend that you cycle off
them after a period of 30 days
or so.
And I want to be very
clear about this,
just because I said cycle
off after a period of 30 days
or so does not mean
that you can't take them
for a shorter period of time.
So for instance, if you
know that you're coming up
on a big week of
stress, well, then you
could take ashwagandha and/or
lion's mane and/or chaga
for that week or just that
week or heading into that week
or in the following
week and then stop.
There's no reason why you
couldn't take them even just
for one day.
Although, the effects tend to
be a bit cumulative, at least,
when we're talking
about buffering anxiety.
In terms of buffering
cortisol, that's
a very potent effect
that as far as we know,
is going to take
place on day one.
Again, keep that cortisol
buffering effect away
from exercise.
At least, don't take
it before exercise.
And try and buffer your cortisol
in the afternoon and evening,
and this is assuming that you're
working a conventional shift
and you're not up all
night and sleeping
all day for sake of shift work.
So hopefully, that
clarifies things
about what adaptogens are.
In fact, I never actually
read the specific question,
but I think I've touched
on a number of issues
that were related to
the specific question.
And then I'll answer the
last portion of the answer
to this question
in a moment, as it
relates to behavioral tools
that can act as adaptogens.
The question,
itself, was there's
a lot of mixed information
out there about adaptogens
like ashwagandha.
And I think that relates to
what I said earlier, which
is that the definition
of an adaptogen
has not really been cemented
in various communities.
It's different in
different communities,
and it's generally used
as a matter of convenience
rather than really strictly
defining what it is.
And hopefully, we've defined it
accurately and broadly enough
today as something
that buffers stress.
The second part of
the question was
what does the scientific
evidence say about adaptogens
and their ability to mediate
body stress response?
They say quite a
lot, and they say
that the stress response can
be buffered substantially
by certain adaptogens.
Mainly, dark leafy greens,
cruciferous vegetables,
ashwagandha, lion's
mane, and chaga,
and of course, all
the behavioral things
that are critical that I
will list off in a moment.
And then the third
portion of the question
is, is there any
solid evidence that
has an effect on
neurotransmitters or the HPA,
which is part of the
stress modulation access?
The best evidence is that
adaptogens can reduce cortisol
itself.
There is very little evidence
that adaptogens can directly
modulate neurotransmitters or
neuromodulators like dopamine,
serotonin, et cetera.
But by adjusting the timing
and levels of cortisol,
especially in the
afternoon and evening,
that is going to have
indirect effects on levels
of dopamine, norepinephrine,
et cetera, and serotonin.
But not direct effects.
So the general contour that
makes for an ideal diurnal
schedule-- you heard
of nocturnal, well,
the opposite that is diurnal,
being awake during the daytime
and asleep at night.
The ideal kind of landscape
of neurotransmitters
is higher levels of dopamine,
norepinephrine, and epinephrine
in the early part of
the day and cortisol,
so-called catecholamines,
dopamine, norepinephrine,
and epinephrine.
And high levels of cortisol
early in the day as
directed by sunlight, exercise,
caffeine, hydration, movement,
all that stuff, being
awake and busy and outside
or indoors with bright
lights and moving
about in the early
part of the day
and into the early afternoon,
that's the best possible way
that we are aware
of to try and get
those catecholamines
released at the highest
levels in the early
part of the day.
And then the ideal
contour of a 24-hour cycle
will be in the later
half of the day.
The evening and nighttime,
you have higher levels
of things like serotonin
the GABAergic system,
all the things that are somewhat
sedative in preparing you
for sleep and lower levels of
the catecholamines and cortisol
as I described before.
So to directly
answer the question,
"Is there any evidence
that adaptogens can
alter your neurotransmitters?"
Yes, but only indirectly.
And yet, that indirect
control over neurotransmitters
is substantial and is important.
And if you do what I described,
such as getting morning
sunlight and ideally, you'd
get a little bit of deliberate
cold water exposure,
by the way, to boost
adrenaline and
norepinephrine and dopamine,
those catecholamines
early in the day.
So quick one-minute
cold shower, even
or a three-minute cold shower,
or if you have access to an ice
bath early in the day,
plus some sunlight,
doesn't matter which
one you do first,
doing that early in
the day is really
going to create that peak of
cortisol, dopamine, epinephrine
early in the day.
I can't emphasize how
beneficial all of that can be.
And exercise, if you can,
early end of the day.
Some people can't exercise
till later in the day.
I'd rather see people
exercise later in the day
than not at all,
provided it does not
disrupt their nighttime
sleep, which of course, sleep
is the foundation of mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
So yes, there is modulation
of neurotransmitters,
but most of those are downstream
of the effects on cortisol
that we've been talking about.
So we've defined
nutritional adaptogens,
supplement-based adaptogens--
although, I don't really
like the word
supplements anymore
unless we're talking
about vitamin supplements
for reasons we
talked about earlier.
And then there's
the third category
of adaptogens, which are the
behavioral tools that you
can use to buffer
stress, which qualifies
those as an adaptogen. I think
it's really important that we
always keep in mind that
yes, there are supplements,
yes, there are prescription
drugs out there.
In fact, there are
prescription drugs
that you can get from a
doctor that will potently
zero out your cortisol.
But most doctors are very
reluctant to prescribe
those drugs because
cortisol provides
a very important and functional
role early in the day.
Behaviors are very effective
at reducing cortisol.
What are the most effective
behaviors to reduce cortisol?
Well, we talked about,
one, to restrict cortisol
the early part of the day, which
is viewing morning sunlight.
But how would you buffer
cortisol in the late afternoon?
It's going to be all
the things associated
with reducing stress.
For instance, 10
minutes or even--
my laboratory and other
laboratories have shown
is even five minutes
a day of just what
would be called mindfulness
meditation, very simple.
You don't need to
overcomplicate this.
You could use a great app
like the Waking Up app
or another app of the sort.
Or, you can simply
sit down, eyes
closed, breathe
through your nose,
and just concentrate
on your breathing.
Every time your mind
drifts to something else,
bring it back to your breathing.
That's shown to reduce stress.
You could do a five-minute
deliberate breath work
practice.
My laboratory has published
some work related to that.
The breath work practice
could be any number of things.
The two that I
recommend the most
would be double inhale,
followed by a full exhale,
and then repeat for a
period of five minutes.
Known to substantially
reduce anxiety, stress,
and the various
physiological systems
associated with arousal.
You could also
use box breathing,
inhale, hold, exhale,
hold for equal durations
for a period of five
minutes, will substantially
reduce stress.
I'm a big fan, as many of
you know, of yoga nidra,
which involves no movement.
It involves just lying
there, listening to a script.
Lots of yoga or scripts
available online.
If you're not interested in the
intentions and other things,
including yoga nidra,
you can buffer stress
using an adaptogen like
NSDR, non-sleep deep breast.
If you're interested in
trying these sorts of things.
There's a NSDR protocol
that's 10 minutes long.
Just put my name,
Huberman, and NSDR
into the search
browser on YouTube.
And Virtusan is provided in
NSDR that's completely zero cost
and works very well
for reducing stress.
It will also help
teach your system
and teach you how to learn to
fall asleep better at night.
So any of those practices, five
to 10-minute breathing practice
or meditation, or
a NSDR yoga nidra.
If you can do longer 20 or
30 minutes in the afternoon,
that's known to buffer
cortisol substantially as well.
Any time you're encountering
stress in real time,
I highly recommend
a tool over and over
because it's so effective.
The fastest way we to
buffer stress and calm down
is the so-called
physiological sigh,
big Inhale through the nose till
your lungs are empty, but then
sneak in a little bit
more air by second inhale,
maximally inflate
the lungs, then
a long exhale until
you're lungs are empty.
One to three of those
will reduce your stress
substantially.
Over time that should
reduce, that is, buffer
your cortisol acting
as an adaptogen.
There are a lot of things.
You can take a hot bath,
you could take a hot shower,
you can listen to
some pleasant music.
Anything that reduces
your stress, technically,
is an adaptogen. So I hope
I've thoroughly answered
your question by yours--
I mean, of course, this answer
is going out to all of you.
This is a question that was
asked by Justine Bevilacqua.
I hope I pronounced
that correctly, Justine.
And thank you for that question.
I think there are
a lot of people
interested in adaptogens.
So now, you can use nutrition
such as cruciferous vegetables,
dark leafy greens.
And I should also
mention, if you're not
ingesting enough
calories each day, well,
then you are going to be
in a mild mode of stress.
That's not to say that some
people shouldn't take in fewer
calories than they burn
in order to lose weight,
some people really need to
do that for their health
or for whatever other reason.
But if you restrict
calories too much,
you are going to
increase cortisol output.
So keep that in mind.
So ingest sufficient calories
for you and for your goals.
Aim to get dark leafy greens
and cruciferous vegetables,
don't overcook them.
If you want to
explore supplements,
the best supplements
to act as adaptogens
are going to be ashwagandha,
lion's mane, and chaga.
One or two or three of
those-- although, if you're
going to pick one, I'd recommend
ashwagandha, 600 milligrams
per day, taken in the
later-half of the day.
And then there are
the behavioral tools
that we just talked about now,
which are anything that reduces
stress can reduce cortisol.
And in doing so, are
technically adaptogens.
If you want to know
more behavioral tools
and other tools for
adjusting stress
and learn more
about adaptogens, we
did a whole episode
called Mastering Stress.
So you can look to
that-- that episode also
pretty clearly defines, I like
to think, what short-term,
medium-term, and long-term
stress really are.
Keep in mind, stress
is part of life.
Learning how to work with
it, how to dance with it,
how to buffer it is terrific.
But zeroing out cortisol
is not the goal.
The goal is to learn to modulate
and control your cortisol,
and that's really what
adaptogens are all about.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this ask-me-anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
ask-me-anything sessions, plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast premium channel,
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel, which,
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to change
the format or anything
about the standard
Huberman Lab podcast,
and to fund research in
particular research done
on human beings.
So not animal models,
but on human beings,
which I think we all
agree is the species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to,
specifically, fund research
that is aimed toward
developing further protocols
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels.
Not just the premium channel,
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast and
other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth and
allow you the opportunity
to support the kind
of research that
provides those kinds of
answers in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do a
dollar-for-dollar match
on all funds raised for research
through the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science-related tools, for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for
the Human Lab premium channel,
again, there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMA's.
You can ask questions and get
answers to your questions.
And you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content such as transcripts
of the AMA's and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab
podcast episodes,
and not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]